ancien port de pêche devenu plaque
tournante de l'industrie pétrolière à
stavanger
la richesse est toujours venu de la mer
et c'est de cette ville du sud ouest de
la norvège que par les travailleurs des
plateformes de forage de la mer du nord
c'est ici aussi que la plupart de ces
plateformes sont construites
dernièrement les chantiers maritimes
tourne au ralenti du moins ceux qui ne
sont pas totalement à l'arrêt non
douze mille employés du secteur
pétrolier ont été licenciés à stavanger
l'eldorado semble terminée terrier
amundsen travaillent dans le secteur
pétrolier sur des plateformes offshore
depuis près de 25 ans avec son poste
d'ingénieur spécialisé et son rôle de
représentant syndical
il se pensait à l'abri mises à pied le
31 décembre
il est aujourd'hui au chômage sans
jusqu'à présent vous avez traversé des
périodes creuses mais je n'avais jamais
été sans emploi
depuis terrier a dépoussiéré son cv et
consacre l'essentiel de son temps à la
recherche d'emploi effet journal interne
soit avant les sites web des grandes
compagnies pétrolières
fish est toujours 40 à 50 en peau de
soigner plus rien dans son malheur
terrier se considèrent tout de même
privilégier car sa maison est presque
payer il avait même réussi à mettre de
l'argent de côté
il est aussi couverts par l'assurance
chômage qui lui offre jusqu'à deux ans
d'indemnités
le bureau d'emploi de stavanger
enregistre depuis plusieurs mois une
hausse d'activité mais de l'aveu même de
ses employés on est loin ici d'être
débordé dans la région de regarde le
taux de chômage est présentement de 2,8
pour cent il y a un an il était de 2,2
cela dit 2,8 pour cent si on compare à
d'autres pays
ce n'est vraiment pas très élevé
effervescence à londres le géant du
pétrole norvégien statoil présente ses
résultats du dernier trimestre écoulé et
ses perspectives pour les prochaines
années
étonnamment même si statoil a perdu les
deux tiers de ses revenus
ses patrons semblent plutôt optimiste
oui nous étions bien préparés à cette
nouvelle situation de prix réduits
nous devons en profiter pour devenir
encore plus solide
il est essentiel d'être flexible ayant
tant que les gros exploitants offshore
nous avons cette flexibilité nous sommes
aux commandes
alors oui aux prêteurs de la flexibilité
le nombre d'employés réduit de 8% en un
an
la rationalisation des coûts aussi un
processus qui ne fait que commencer et
la flexibilité
c'est surtout l'arrêt des exploitations
non rentables pour se concentrer sur de
nouveaux gisements jugé très prometteur
le site johann verre d'eau est la plus
belle chose au monde un gisement énorme
qui va produire pour 50 ans avec un prix
de revient à moins de 40 dollars le
baril vienne en norvège ne semble en
mesure d' entamer l'optimisme ambiant
si les prévisions de croissance ont été
ramené de 4 à 2 pour cent
on est loin ici de parler de crise
économique et le budget de l'état
continuent d'afficher des surplus année
après année
naxos le bas prix du pétrole n'aura
aucune influence sur le budget de
l'année à venir en place
l' arme secrète de la norvège c'est sa
décision
il ya 25 ans d'arrêter de dépenser
l'argent du pétrole pour le mettre de
côté et l'investir pour les générations
futures au mur on est de staline entre
des bleus font atteint maintenant 900
milliards de dollars deux fois le
produit national brut de la norvège un
gigantesque bas de laine qui continue de
croître à l'infini car le gouvernement
n'en touche que les dividendes en hausse
constante
évidemment le gros avantage est qu on
pourra toujours utiliser les revenus du
fonds du pétrole dans le budget de
l'état ce qui nous rend moins
vulnérables aux fluctuations des prix du
pétrole
l'exemple de la norvège est souvent cité
à travers le monde
un modèle qui a permis ce petit pays
scandinaves de se développer une vitesse
fulgurante
le pnb par habitant dépasse ici les cent
mille dollars par an mais surtout le
modèle a fait ses preuves permettant à
la norvège de traverser sans mal toutes
les crises depuis 25 ans et pourtant si
le pays est aujourd'hui le premier
exportateur de pétrole en europe
la recette norvégienne elle ne s'est à
peu près jamais exporté